اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نحن استعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز
المستجدات وفي العناوين
بيان سعودي ايراني يعلن الترتيب لاعاده
فتح السفارتين وبحث استئناف الرحله الجويه
بين البلدين
في تصعيد جديد مستوطنون يقتحمون باحات
الاقصى والمجلس بل ومجلس الامن يعقد جلسه
جلسه استثنائيه بعد توال الانتهاكات
بعد تاجيل التوقيع الاتفاق النهائي في
السودان البرهان يؤكد على ضروره استكمال
العمليه السياسيه
فرنسا تستعد ليوم جديد من التظاهرات
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد والسلطات
تتاهب بالالاف من عناصر الامن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا وقاعه السعوديه وايران
بيانا مشتركا عقب لقاء وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان والايراني
حسين امير عبداللهيان في بكين وقال البيان
انه تم الاتفاقه على بدء ترتيبات اعاده
فتح السفارتين والقن
الجويه وتسهيل التاشيرات للمواطنين كما تم
الاتفاق على استئناف تبادل زيارات
المسؤولين ووفود القطاع الخاص اضافه الى
تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الامني الموقعه عام
2001 والتعاون العام الموقعه عام
1998 ودعاء وزير خارج السعودي نظير ايراني
لزياره الرياض واكد القيامه بكل ما يلزم
لتحقيق امني واستقرار المنطقه
مشاهدينا معنا هاتفيا الكاتب الصحفي محمد
السعد اهلا بك سيد محمد معنا في هذه
النشره ونتحدث كما تبعث معنا عن اجتماع
سعودي ايراني رسمي هو الاول من نوعه منذ
اكثر من سبع سنوات كيف قراته بدايه من حيث
التوقيت والدلاله
طبعا يمكن قراءته الحقيقه في سياق هرتز
الطريقه التي
وقعت قبل اربعه اسابيع بالدقه يعني
وهذا واضح بان يعني هذه الخارطه
تسير على مراحل واضحه
وثابته لدى الطرفين
لو تتذكر كانت الاتفاقيه قالت بان هناك 60
يوما ستكون هي مرحله اختبار اوليه
لاستئناف العلاقات بشكل كامل ورسمي ونحن
اليوم قطعنا 30 يوما من اول الاتفاق وهذا
دليل على ان العلاقات يعني تنضج شيئا
فشيئا وانا حط في التاريخ تنفذ بشكل جيد
وهذا مؤشر الحقيقه على انه
الطريقه التي قامت بها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في استئناف علاقاتها ايران كانت
طريقه ناجحه لان كل الخطوات التي تلت
الاتفاق المبدئي كانت خطوات دقيقه وعدت
الى ما نحن
عليه اليوم اجتماع اليوم ايضا تمخضى عنه
تفعيل اتفاقيات التعاون الامني بين
البلدين تسهيل منحه التاشيرات واستئناف
الرحلات الجويه بين البلدين ايضا ما مدى
التقارب الذي قد تحققه هذه البنود بين
البلدين
اعيد مره اخرى بان هذا ضمن ايضا خفض
الطريق سيتم استكمال كل الخطوات بناء على
ردود الافعال على الارض كما قلنا باقوال
لا تكفي فقط وانما الافعال على الارض هناك
خطوات مطلوبه الحقيقه من الطرف الايراني
وبدا تنفيذها فعليا هناك مزيد من الخطوات
يجب تنفيذها استئناف العلاقات الاقتصاديه
والامنيه
بشكل مبدئي هذا الشيء يعني مبشر ولكن ايضا
هناك خطوات استثماريه كبرى قد قد تتحول
الى ايران خلال الاشهر القادمه في حال
استمر الحقيقه العلاقات هذه نقطه محمد اود
ان اسالك عن ان مستقبل هذه العلاقه يرتبط
ربما كما تفضلت بتحديات كبيره وصعوبات
ايضا اتحدث عن اقتصاديين متنافسين لانهم
يعتمدان بالضبط على النفط اعتمادا كاملا
هناك ايضا نتحدث عن العقوبات الغربيه على
ايران كيف يمكن للسعوديه ان تحدث او تخلق
حاله من التوازن في علاقتها وفق هذه
المعطيات
اسمح لي هناك اختلاف الحقيقه جوهري في
الاقتصادين السعودي والايراني الاقتصاد
الايراني
اقتصاد متاخر كثيرا لهذه السعوديه تقدم
نموذجا جيدا لاختصار افتح هذا بعيدا عن
النفط ويحاول الحقيقه بناء اقتصاد موازي
قادر على تلبيه التحديات اعتقد ان هذا
النموذج السعودي اليوم في المنطقه ستستفيد
منه ايران بشكل كبير
ودخول الاستثمارات السعوديه والخبره
التجاريه السعوديه ايران ستحدث فرقا كبيرا
داخل ايران ايران اليوم في حاجه الى مزيد
من الاستثمارات الى خلق مزيد من الفرص
الوظيفيه ايران لديها الحقيقه موروث ثقافي
وليدها موروث
اقتصادي قديم ولكن في حاجه الى مكنله هذا
الاقتصاد تطويره وتفعيله وتخدم السعوديه
قادره على تقديم هذه الميزه في ظل الحقيقه
التبادل المنافع الذي يمكن
ان تحمله العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه
ايضا هناك استقرار امني في المنطقه مطلوب
بالحقيقه بتحقيق هذه التنميه المستدامه
التي تبحث عنها دور المنطقه هذه السيوله
الامنيه التي يشهدها العالم ايضا قد تؤثر
على المنطقه وقد تفجرها الاتفاق السعودي
الايراني
في الحقيقه سيقلل مخاطر هذه السيوله
الامنيه وسيحاول الحقيقه الحد من المخاطر
والبناء على علاقات
ثابته باحترام بامن واستقرار الدولتين
وايضا امنوا استقرار الفضاء العربيه الذي
تجاوره شكرا لك كنت معنا هاتفيا من جده
الكاتب الصحفي محمد السائد تحياتي سيد
محمد
في تطورات الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
يتواصل التوتر في باحات الاقصى اذ اقتحمت
مجموعه من المستوطنين الاسرائيليين صباح
اليوم المسجد الاقصى وصل حمايه مشدده من
القوات الاسرائيليه التي فرضت قيودا فجر
اليوم على دخول المصلين الى الحرم القدسي
لاداء صلاه الفجر وفي وقت تواصلت ايضا
المواجهات في ازقه البلده القديمه في
القدس بين الفلسطينيين والشرطه
الاسرائيليه ومن المنتظر المشاهدين ان
يعقد مجلس الامن جلسه طارئه اليوم الخميس
لبحث الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه للمسجد
الاقصى وكانت القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحمت
باحات المسجد الاقصى امس لمنع المصلين من
الاعتكاف لليله الثانيه على التوالي
هكذا بدا المشهد في المصلى القبلي وساحات
المسجد الاقصى لساعات حيث اقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه المكان واعتدت على المعتكفين
المصلى القبلي تحول الى ساحه معركه لليوم
الثاني على التوالي في اعنف اقتحامات
واعتداءات منذ العام 2000
لم يعتد عليها بهذه الوحشيه ولكن هناك
رسائل واضحه بانهم سيستخدمون العنف المفرط
وهذه احد الاساليب للسيطره من خلال
تخويفين بعد اخلاء الاقصى من الفلسطينيين
امتدت المواجهات الى ازقه البلده القديمه
في القدس الشرقيه المحتله كما انتقلت
تصعيد الى مدن داخل الخط الاخضر وفي الضفه
الغربيه وعلى جبهه قطاع غزه ايضا
[موسيقى]
يتهم الفلسطينيون اسرائيل بانها تلجا في
كل شهر رمضان الى توتير الاوضاع وترمي الى
فرض وقائع من خلال اقتحامات المستوطنين
والشرطه بقرار سياسي
اعتداءات اسرائيليه واقتحامات غير مسبوقه
منذ العام 2000 للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
تكرس بها اسرائيل وفق الفلسطينيين
المعادله التي تقول ان شراره التصعيد
تنطلق من الاقصى وصولا الى باقي الجبهات
على جانبي الخط الاخضر وقطاع غزه زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الشرقي المحتله
اظهرت صور متدهوره الاقتحام مجموعه من
المستوطنين اباحات المسجد الاقصى بحمايه
مشدده من القوات الاسرائيليه نتابع
وعلى حدود غزه اعلان متحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه تم رصد اطلاق صاروخين من
قطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل مساء الاربعاء
مشيرا الى ان احدهما سقط داخل القطاع
والاخر في منطقه السياج الحدودي واضاف ان
ذلك ادى الى تفعيل نظام الانذار من
الصواريخ هذا وافادت وسائل اعلام
الفلسطينيه بسماع دوي انفجارات في بلدات
قريبه من بئر السابع في النقب الغربي
وكذلك سماع انطلاق صفارات الانذار
ومن القسم مشاهدينا تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه
الاقتحامات في القدس ام ان الامور بدات
تعود لطبيعتها
اهلا بك احمد يعني فعليا بعد الليله
الثانيه من الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه للمسجد
الاقصى والمصلى القبلي ما زال التوتر
موجودا ولكن يعني كان منذ صباح اليوم ايضا
اقتحامات كبيره للمسجد الاقصى الشرطه
الاسرائيليه منعت فجر اليوم اعداد كبيره
من الشبان المقدسيين والفلسطينيين من اداء
صلاه الفجر داخل المسجد المسجد الاقصى
وقاموا باداء الصلاه خارج اسوار المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ولكن سمحت فقط للاشخاص
اكبر من عمر اربعين عاما ايضا كان هناك
اربع مجموعات من قبل المستوطنين بحمايه
اسرائيليه مشدده كان اقتحموا المسجد
الاقصى والساحات مسجد صباح اليوم قبل
دقائق فقط يعني كنا نشاهد ايضا
اقتحام جديد من هنا داخل ساحات المسجد
الاقصى ولكن يعني الاوضاع توصف الهدوء
الحذر بالرغم من التوترات وانتشار اعداد
كبيره من الشرطه الاسرائيليه قامت ايضا
بتعزيز المكان ونشرت اعداد من قواتها في
البلده القديمه وايضا على ابواب المسجد
الاقصى تاهبا من توتر الاوضاع مجددا يعني
محدث بالامس يتكرر نتحدث عن اقتحامات
بدايه من القوات الاسرائيليه تليها
اقتحامات من المستوطنين مدعوم ايضا ومحميه
بهذه القوات الاسرائيليه الى متى سيستمر
هذا السيناريو هل هو مرتبط بفتره الاعياد
اليهودي الحاليه
على ما يبدو ان هذا المشهد سوف يتكرر حتى
انتهاء الاعياد اليهوديه وبالرغم من تدخل
ومحاوله تدخل الدول الاجنبيه وحتى الدول
العربيه مثل مصر الاردن ويعني كان هناك
اعداد كبيره ايضا من الدول التي قامت يعني
التنديد وقالت انها لا توافق على ما تقوم
به الشرطه الاسرائيليه داخل المصلى القبل
من اعتداءات على الشبان واقتحامات ولكن
على ما يبدو ان اسرائيل ما زالت مصره على
هذه الاقتحامات بالرغم من اي شيء حتى يعني
ايضا يجب ان نسلط الضوء على شيء وهو يعني
ان قيام مستوطن باطلاق النار على فلسطيني
ليله امس ما ادى الى اصابته بكتفه يعني
ربما لم يتم التسليط الضوء على هذا الشيء
وهو امر خطير وجود اعداد كبيره من
المستوطنين في البلده القديمه في القدس هم
مسلحين اما الان يقومون باستخدام اسلحتهم
ضد الفلسطينيين العزل داخل البلده القديمه
وهذا امر ايضا خطير ربما سوف يؤدي الى
تفجير الاوضاع اكثر من ذلك هناك ايضا يعني
الشبان الفلسطينيين سوف يعلنون غدا بجمعه
غضب وسيتم خروج
الوقت من القدس كنت معنا مراسل العربيه لا
نكون غاصي تحياتي
في مستهل زيارته للصين التي تستغرق ثلاثه
ايام التقى الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون رئيس
المجلس الوطني الشعبي الصيني وبحسب ستركز
السيار الزياره على ثلاثه محاور منها
القضاء الاستراتيجيه والازمات الدوليه
والتعاون في مواجهه التحديات العالميه
الكبرى وكذلك العلاقات الاقتصاديه او
نشاهد مشاهدينا ان نتابع معكم ايضا هذه
الصور المباشره لهذا الاجتماع بين رئيس
رئيس الصيني والرئيس الذي يزور الصين هذه
الايام كما نتابع في الخبر العاجل الرئيس
الصيني
وفرنسا قادرتان على تجاوز الاختلافات في
ظل التغيرات العالميه
ايضا الرئيس الصيني كان يقول ان
العلاقات مع فرنسا تمضي في مسار ايجابي
والخارجيه الصيني قالت قبل ذلك ان
العلاقات مع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي تتطور
بشكل سريع ومتكامل
كل ذلك مشاهدين ياتي في سياق الزياره التي
يجرها الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الى
بكين وتستمر ثلاثه ايام وقد رافقته فيها
ايضا رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ايضا عدد كبير من الوزراء ورجال الاعمال
الذين سيوقعوا بعضهم عقودا مع شركات صينيه
لدي القناعه في التحدث عن اوكرانيا وكذلك
جميع النزاعات الكبرى والمواقف الصعبه حول
العالم ايضا ولدي القدره على الوصول الى
تحليل مشترك وبناء مسار موحد امر ضروري
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الصين تتعهد برد حازم على اللقاءات
الامريكيه مع زعيمه تايوان
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اتهمت الخارجيه
الصينيه الولايات المتحده بانتهاك مبدا
الصين الواحده عبر التواطئ لدعم استقلال
تايوان قبل هذا شجره وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
لقاء رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كيف المكاثي وقالت
الوزاره في بيان انصينا تعارض بشده جميع
اشكال هذا التفاعل الرسمي واي زياره يقوم
بها زعيم تايواني للولايات المتحده تحت اي
مسمن او ذريعه واضافت الوزاره ان الجيش
الصينيه سيبقى في حاله تاهب قصوى وانه
سيحمي بحزم سياده الصين وسلامه اراضيها
وكذلك استلام والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
والى فرنسا مشاهدينا التي تستعد ليوم جديد
من التظاهرات بدعوه من النقابات العماليه
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد حيث سيشمل هذا
التحرك العمالي والشعبي الجديد عده مدن
فرنسيه هذا هو اعلن وزير الداخليه ان 11
الفا وخمسمائه عنصر عنصر امن سيواكبون
المشاركين في هذا اليوم الاحتجاجي الحادي
عشر وكانت جوله المحادثات التي جرت
الاربعاء بين رئيسه الوزراء
وممثلي النقابات العماليه عفوا قد انتهت
الى الفشل كما قال نقابيون شاركوا في
الاجتماعات مشهرين الى ان بون لم تظهر اي
انفتاح لناحيه تحقيق مطلبهم بسحب قانون
رفع سن التقاعد
[موسيقى]
ومن باريس مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مدير مكتب
العربيه حسين قنيبر اهلا بك حسين وكيف بدت
باريس وبقيه المدن الفرنسيه صباح اليوم
والتي تستعد لهذه التظاهرات
الحاشده حسين
نعم احمد صباح الخير هذا التحرك الواسع
النطاق اليوم الذي سيشمل عده مدن عبر
فرنسا عده مدن كبرى ومتوسطه وصغرى هو
التحرك الحادي عشر اليوم الحادي عشر
للاحتجاج على رفع سن التقاعد التظاهر
الاكبر ستكون بطبيعه الحال في العاصمه
باريس حيث سينطلق المتظاهرون عند الساعه
الثانيه من بعد الظهر من ساحه انفاليد نحو
ساحه ايطاليا
التحرك سيشمل عده قطاعات ابرزها النقل
والصحه والطاقه والتعليم والنقابات بدات
تحركا من نوع جديد وردتنا قبل دقائق من
الان معلومات عن تحرك بدا بعيده الساعه
العاشره بتوقيت المحلي اي قبل ربع ساعه من
الان بدا في احد اقسام مطار شارل دو غول
هذا التحرك يعيق حركه المسافرين هو القسم
الدولي من مطار شارد غول هناك رحلات
داخليه ورحلات اوروبيه ورحلات مع مناطق
اخرى في العالم تنطلق من شارد جول الاغلاق
الحاصل في هذا المطار حاليا يشمل طائرات
يشمل رحلات نحو كل من الامارات وقطر
والمانيا وكندا طبعا هو تحرك عابر ستقوم
القوى الامنيه
بمحاوله اعاده ترتيب وتنسيق الوضع بشكل
تتمكن هذه الشركات التي اطالتها هذه
التحركات من ان يعني تقوم بتنظيم رحلاتها
بشكل المعتاد كما ذكرت احمد
11,500 عنصر امن سيواكبون هذه التظاهرات
عبر فرنسا من بينهم
4,200 في باريس وحدها كما توقع مذكره
للاستخبارات الداخليه ان يشارك ما بين
600,800 الف شخص في التظاهرات عبر فرنسا
من بينهم ما بين 60 الف وتسعون الفا في
العاصمه وحدها انهم امتحان قوه جديد بين
الحكومه والشارع الحكومه تحاول
يعني اعطاء الانطباع بانها تتعاون لكن
النقابات قالت ان المحادثات التي جرت بين
ممثليها ورئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث لم تكن
مثمره ولم تؤدي الى اي نتيجه احمد طيب
حسين فيما يتعلق يعني لو عقدنا مقارنه
بسيطه بين اعداد المشاركين في هذه
التظاهرات
الان ومنذ بدايه هذه الازمه هل نتحدث عن
مسار انحداري لهذه الاعداد ام على عكس
مسار تصاعدي
هو تصاعدي على المستوى السياسي لكنه
انحداري نسبيا على مستوى المشاركين في
التظاهرات والذين تتراجع اعدادهم نسبيا من
يوم احتجاجي الى يوم اخر الحكومه تراهن
على تعب المتظاهرين وتراهن على تراجع هذه
الاعداد اقول تراجع نسبي فقط وليس تراجعا
كبيرا والشارع عبر النقبات واحزاب اليسار
يراهن على مواصله التحرك وصولا الى اليوم
الذي سيصدر فيه المجلس الدستوري حكمه في
قانون رفع سن التقاعد المجلس الدستوري
سيعلن حكمه يوم الرابع عشر من هذا الشهر
الحكومه لا تتحدث عن مخارج حتى الان لكن
بعض المراقبين لهذا الوضع يقولون ان ثم
احتمالات في الافق هل يلجا ماكرون الى حل
هذه الحكومه وتشكيل حكومه جديده هل يلجا
الى استفتاء هل تحصل مفاوضات جديده مع كل
ذلك لناحيه المفاوضات مرغوب بقرار المجلس
الدستوري اما انه سيقبل قانون رفع سن
التقاعد ويعتبره دستوريا بكامل بنوده ام
انه سيرفض بعض البنود فيعادي التفاوض حول
هذا البعض المرفوض او انه
يقبل القانون تماما وهذا يحرك الشارع
مجددا لانه سيثير غضبا في الشارع واذا رفض
المجلس الدستوري قانون رفع سن التقاعد فان
على الحكومه ان تقوم بخطوات جديده وتعود
الى التفاوض من النقطه الصفر احمد شكرا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من فايروس
كنت معنا مدير مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر
تحيه الحسين
في السودان اكد رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان العزم على استكمال العمليه
السياسيه في البلاد مشيرا الى ان تاجير
توقيع الاتفاق السياسي يهدف الى وضع الاطر
المتينه للمحافظه على الثوره ولفت البرهان
الى ان جميع الاطراف تعمل الان لاكمال
النقاش بشان القضايا المتبقيه هذا هو
اعلنت قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان
تاجير توقيع الاتفاق السياسي الذي كان
مقررا اليوم لعدم استكمال الجوانب الخاصه
بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري وضعت قوى الحريه
والتغيير في بيان السودانيين للمشاركه
الفاعله في مواكب السادس من ابريل في
العاصمه والولايات وشددت على ضروره التمسك
بالسلميه كما طالبت قوى الحريه والتغيير
الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه بحمايه المواكب
الشعبيه محجره من اين اي تعامل عنيف بل
محذره من اي تعامل عنيف تجاه المشاركين
نفت مصادر عسكريه سودانيه مطلعه وجود اي
توترات عسكريه في الخرطوم واكدت ان القوات
المسلحه كعهدها ووفقا مؤسساتها ونظم عملها
تبسط سيطرتها على مواطن الامن في السودان
كافه ورا ترتيبات الخاصه لديها للتصدي لاي
اخطار ربما تنشا على امن العاصمه او
البلاد
التقى وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد
بن سلمان رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه
اليمنيه الدكتور رشاد العليمي واعضاء
المجلس هو قال وزير الدفاع السعودي على
عبر حسابه على تويتر قال انه خلال اللقاء
تم استعراض عمق العلاقات الاخويه التي
تجمع البلدين الشقيقين مؤكدا استمرار دعم
المملكه المتواصل اليمن ولمجلس القياده
الرئاسي الياباني في كافه المجالات مما
يسهم في الوصول الى حل سياسي شامل ينهي
الازمه اليمنيه نشره مستمره مشاهدينا
وفيها بعد الفاصل منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الامريكيه تدخل حيز الخدمه في اوكرانيا لا
يستبعد الانسحاب من
اصوات سمعناها اذاعه الشباب والرياضه من
القاهره حفظناها متى استعبدتم الناس وقد
ولدتهم
امهاتهم احرارا شكلت ذكرياتنا وتربينا
عليها اصوات
بيان سعودي ايراني يعلن الترتيب لاعاده
فتح السفارتين وبحث استئناف الرحلات
الجويه بين البلدين
في تصعيد جديد مستوطنون يقتحمون باحث
الاقصى ومجلس الامن يعقد جلسه الاستثنائيه
بعد توائم
بعد تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق النهائي في
السودان البرهان يؤكد على ضروره استكمال
العمليه السياسيه
فرنسا تستعد ليوم جديد من التظاهرات
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد والسلطات
تتاهب بالاف بل بالالاف من عناصر الامن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشف صحيفه
للتحدث مع روسيا بشان شبه جزيره القرمن
اذا نجح الهجوم المضاد وفي تفاصيل قال
كبير مستشاري الرئيس الاوكراني اندريس
بيها للصحيفه قال ان كييف مستعده لمناقشه
مستقبل شبه جزيره القرم مع موسكو اذا وصلت
قوتها الى حدود شبه جزيره القرم واكدت بها
انه اذا نجحت بلاده في تحقيق اهدافها
الاستراتيجيه في ساحه المعركه وعند وصول
القوات الاوكرانيه للحدود الاداريه مع شبه
جزيره القرم فحينها ستكون اوكرانيا مستعده
لفتح صفحه دبلوماسيه مشيرا في الوقت ذاته
الى انه لا يستبعد التحرير بقوات الجيش
اعلنت هيئه الطوارئ في مقاطعه
الجوي الروسي تمكنت من اسقاط سته صواريخ
مارس وذلك خلال تصديها للقصف الاوكراني
الذي على مدينه ميلوتو بول في مقاطعه
واكدت هيئه الطوارئ في المقاطعه ان
اوكرانيا حاولت شن هجوم صاروخين على
المدينه لكن انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه
ردت لتسقط جميع صواريخ السته مشيره الى ان
الهجوم لم ينتج عنه اصابات او اضرار
اعلن قائد القوات الاوكرانيه المشتركه
سيرجي نايف ان منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الامريكيه افنجرز دخلت الخدمه في الجيش
الاوكراني ونشر مقطع فيديو يظهر بعض القطع
من هذا النظام الدفاعي موضحا ان عناصر
الجيش العاملين على المنظومه قد تدربوا
على استخدامها في المانيا
ونشيل هذا الخبر عجل الدفاع البريطانيه
تقول ان الجيش الروسيه قال قائد الدائره
الشرقيه رستمرادوف بعد خسائر في فوليدر
بالعوده الى سياق هذه النشره المشاهدين
اقرا رئيس
ولا يجب فقدان افراد بسبب الحصار لكنه
ايضا اضاف ان شحنه الذخيره من حلفاء
اوكرانيا ستعزز الدفاعات العسكريه وستمكن
جيش من المحاربه بشكل اسرع ليس في بخسب بل
في جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه
متابعه لقضيه محاكمه ترامب ان قالت قناه
سي ان ان عن مسؤولين بمجلس الامن القومي
خلال شهادتهم لدى هيئه المحلفين بنيويورك
قولهم انهم ابلغ ترامب عندما كان رئيسا
انه لا يستطيع حجز الات التصويت وذلك بعد
ان اشتكى من التزوير واتهم الديمقراطيين
نتائج انتخابات 2020 قناه ايضا حاول قلب
خسارته الى فوز من خلال سعيه لمصادره الات
التصويت الالكتروني انذاك ما يعيد قضيه
انتخابات 2020 الى الواجهه من جديد هذا
وقال محامي رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب انما يحصل بخصوص القضايا الموجهه
لموكله هي عمليه تسليح للنظام القانوني
وهي سابقه في تاريخ السياسه الامريكيه يجب
على كل الاشخاص سواء المؤيدين او
المعارضين للترامب معرفه ذلك نتابعه
على لائحه الاتهام ومعرفه ما هو القانون
بخصوص الحملات الانتخابيه الفيدراليه
يعتقد اننا نقترب من هيئه المحلفين اذا
وصلنا الى هيئه المحلفين اعتقدوا ان اي
شخص سواء كان على اليمين او معارضا سياسيا
للترامب او لصالحه سيرى الحقيقه انه تسليح
نظام القانوني
حقيقه تمت كتابتها في الذيل من اكبر منشور
على الانترنت في العالم حيث كشفوا حقيقه
ان بعض افراد عائله القاضي عملوا مع نائبه
الرئيس
الحاليس هذه حقيقه واقعيه وليست هجوما على
القاضي او عائلته تعليقات الرئيس ترامب لم
تحرض على العنف اطلاقا
اذا مشاهدينا تمثل المشاريع الصغيره لبيع
الوجبات الخفيفه والمشروبات القتل الوحيد
لكثير من اليمنيين ومنها يؤثرون متطلبات
شهر رمضان وعيد الفطر لاسرهم وتنتشر عشرات
العربات والبسطات في مشهد متكرر وفي تنافس
لتوفير ماكولات سريعه وخفيفه للصائمين
وبيعها ايضا باسعار مخفضه
[موسيقى]
في عربه صغيره يقوم عبد السلام بتجهيز
انواع من السمبوسه والمشروبات وبيعها
للماره في احد اسواق محافظه مارب اليمنيه
للعام الخامس على التوالي ينفذ هذا
المشروع الموسميه مع حلول شهر رمضان
ويكسب منه قوت اسرته اغلق عبد السلام محلا
تجاريا كان يصرع فيه هذه الاشياء لعدم
قدرته على دفع الايجار ووجد الخير في
مشروع صغير لا يكلفه شيئا حاله كحال كثير
من اليمنيين هذا المشروع افعله بدايه كل
رمضان كل سنه هذا الموسم الرابع او الخامس
تقريبا واحتمال اعتمادنا عليه يعني بشكل
رسمي ومصاريف رمضان مصاريف العيد وكذا
والحمد لله ربك كريم مشي امورنا سابره
الله يشتغل المشاريع البسيطه هي الناجحه
وتوفر اكثر بحيث انه ايار المحلات غاليه
بشكل كبير اه هناك ما بعض الانسان ما يريد
ما يدخل
يوقعله دخل الا في رمضان من من دخل هذه
المشاريع الصغيره وتخفف عليه قبل موعد
الافطار تزدحم الشوارع بباعه الخضار
والوجبات الخفيفه الكل ينادي زبائنه عبر
مكبرات الصوت فطورك يا صائم
مشهد مالوف وتنافس بين المطاعم واصحاب
المشاريع الصغيره هذه التي يفضلها
المواطنون لانخفاض اسعارها ومسانده
اصحابها على الكسب والاستمرار قمنا بشوايه
في الشوارع ماشي معانا محلات
وخفضنا الاسعار من 4000 ريال في رمضان هذه
قبل المغرب بالذات لها طلب عند الناس
سمبوسه عصير
واشياء خفيفه وفيها الحمد لله مصدر رز
ممتاز الحلويات الشعبيه يجد سوقها رواجا
خلال شهر رمضان
وتنتشر عشرات العربات لبيع اصناف معينه
منها في ظل الازمه المعيشيه تمثل هذه
المشاريع قوتها كثير من اليمنيين في رمضان
وتعد مصدر دخلهم الوحيد محمود الحميدي
العربيه مارب
[موسيقى]
باقه من النجوم المغاربه اشتهروا في مجال
الكوميديا يجتمعون في العمل الرمضاني دير
النيه والذي يحظى بمشاهده عاليه من قبل
الجمهور المغربي نتابع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا تتنافس مختلفه القنوات المغربيه على
جذب المشاهد بالتطرق الى عدد متنوع من
القبائل الاجتماعيه ضمن باقي من الاعمال
الدراميه والكوميديه الجديده بمناسبه
الشهر رمضان من بينها اعمال لقيت نجاح
كبير في المواسم الماضيه واخرى جديده ابرز
هذه الاعمال مسلسل ديرو انديه كوميديا ولا
دراما كل عمل كتبقى عنده الخصوصيه ديالو
كتبقى عنده المتعه ديال الاشتغال فيه
كنشتغلو كيكون الخدمه كبيره
الشروط اللي تتماشى مع المبادئ ديال
العائلات المغربيه في الدراما عليهم
[موسيقى]
ما حسيتيش بالدور وما حسيتيش بذاك الشخصيه
اللي انت كتجسدها ما توصلش للمتابعين
الجمهور تفاعل مع العمل بشكل كبير لذلك
لناخذ وقفه مع بعض تغريداتهم
[موسيقى]
دول عده حول العالم تحضر تيك توك عن هواتف
الموظفين الرسميين ويبدو ان تطبيقها يتجه
نحو الحظر العام في البلدان فحتى الصين
نفسها لا تسمحوا باستخدامه
معركه رقميه يخوضها العالم ضد احد اكثر
التطبيقات شعبيه من الولايات المتحده الى
اوروبا واستراليا
لتحضر تطبيق تيك توك بسبب مخاوف الامن
السيبراني
[موسيقى]
التطبيق الصيني الذي اشتاح العالم اصبح
مصدر تهديدا على امن الولايات المتحده
بحسب الحكومه الامريكيه فمخاوف تسريب
معلومات المستخدمين الى الحكومه الصينيه
ادى بالاداره الامريكيه الى حظر التطبيق
على الهواتف الحكوميه ونقاش حول احتماليه
حظر عام في البلاد
مخاوف بالعدوى انتقلت الى اوروبا لتمنعه
عده دول من هواتف الموظفين الرسميين على
راسهم بريطانيا والتي غرمت تيك توك 15
مليون دولار لانتهاك قانون حمايه البيانات
وتبعتها استراليا
[موسيقى]
الذي يسمح بنشر اي محتوى بحدود رقابه
فضفاضه ادى بالعديد من الدول لمنع
استخدامه بعد سيطره حركه طالبان على الحكم
في افغانستان حضر التيك توك في صيف 2021
لتليها باكستان وتعزو قرارها الى التاثير
غير الاخلاقي للمحتوى ويكون سبب ذاته في
اندونيسيا وبنغلاديش اما الهند فهي على
حظر مستمر للتطبيق منذ 2022 على خلفيه
النزاعات الحدوديه بينها وبين الصين
[موسيقى]
بينما يدافع تيك توك عن الشركه الام باي
دانس مؤكدا انه لا يشارك اي معلومات مع
الحكومه الصينيه تمنع الصين نفسها استخدام
التطبيق خوفا من التاثيرات التي يسببها
خاصه على فئه المراهقين لتستبدله بتطبيقات
اخرى مثل
ذات رقابه مشدده وساعات استخدام محدده اذا
عمر العربيه
هو قبل الختام مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز
العناوين
بيان سعودي ايراني يعلن الترتيب لاعاده
فتح السفارتين وبحث استئناف الرحلات
الجويه بين البلدين
في تصعيد جديد مستوطنون يقتحمون باحث
الاقصى ومجلس الامن يعقد جلسه استثنائيه
بعد توالي الانتهاكات
بعد تاجيل التوقيع لاتفاق النهائي في
السودان البرهان يؤكد على ضروره استكمال
العمليه السياسيه
[تصفيق]
فرنسا تستعد ليوم جديد من التظاهرات
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد والسلطات
تتاهب بالالاف من عناصر الامن
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]